when we moved in uh we just like slept
on a futon at connors for like a week
and after sydney was just like why would
why would we sleep on the floor peasants
sleep on the floor and me
being the asian like i every time i go
like to thailand i'd always sleep on the
floor at my grandma's place and i'm just
like
there's something comforting about
sleeping on the floor and i don't know
what it is but
i sleep i i just realized that whenever
we'd go to like onsens or ryokans or
whatever you'd sleep on the futon floors
fusion mattresses
and you just get the best night of sleep
you have in your life and i don't know
what it is i think it might be because
like the tatami or the floor or whatever
it is you're you're sleeping on the
hard surface yeah it like flattens your
back out yeah so i guess that just like
naturally gives you better sleepers
but i agree like i don't know i get the
best sleep in a futon yeah so like i
we just we just we just decided why not
just [ __ ] sleep on the floor like we
just we just got to match
then you miss out on like the you know
when you wake up and you're like oh [ __ ]
then you just kind of like sit on the
bed with like your legs
on the floor yeah you're just like [ __ ]
i gotta get up but like you're not
feeling like do you love that feeling
yeah
i kind of like that i hate that i don't
want to get out of bed right away
but i want to kind of get up and i want
to put my you know i want to try to get
ready i'll hype myself up tonight
for me there's only two states there's
lying in the bed
on my phone or just out of bed yeah well
you never you never like sit there at
this edge of the bed
being like like [ __ ] i gotta get up no
like i i kind of realized
that i i i want to spend the least time
in my bedroom as
physically possible right and i feel
like you get a better night's sleep if
like your bedroom is
just for sleeping because they're like i
remember in my old place especially when
like we saw i started youtube and we
were working literally with my bed next
to me
yeah i would get like the worst night's
sleep every time because i could not
like
i could not go in my bedroom and just
you know go on my bed and just like go
into sleep mode
like i found that once i
positioned it so i would spend the least
time in my bed as possible
i would get much better sleep yeah my
place two places ago now
was yeah it was the same like you guys
you guys been there before the tiny
apartment i had
the [ __ ] tiny tiny apartment the
anime man couch with all the plushies
when i was like 18 i probably would have
thought that was a cool ass apartment
no when i first moved in it was a cool
awesome yeah when you get older you're
like ah
but then i very quickly realized that if
you're where you work
is in the same room or next to where you
sleep
yeah you get the worst sleep yeah you
get the worst productive
like the worst productivity you just
can't do anything because it's like
i could just turn over and literally
walk half a meter
and just sleep if i wanted to yeah it's
like how can you concentrate in a room
like that yeah i don't know
i feel like there was parts where i
enjoyed it like i liked the fact that i
could just kind of like
turn my monitor towards my bed and i
could just watch it because sometimes
watching stuff on the tv
it's real pain in the ass because like
you know
on pc you can just get the website up
and then you can throw it on the monitor
right it's easy on a tv you got to [ __ ]
around with like all the chromecast [ __ ]
you got to figure out
which apps work for my tv which don't
you know the pc it's like whatever i
mean it's not it's not that much
yeah it's like five more minutes worth
of work that i don't want
and also i used to have a set up that i
really liked where i had like uh i had
like a
next to my bed i had a keyboard with
like a track pad on it
right so i would just like [ __ ] fly
this [ __ ] in my bed
that's how people get bedridden i think
i was like getting there i was trial
running
yeah yeah yeah i mean yeah if i was a
bed ridden at least i know the system
like i had
your work yeah i had it all set up you
know it was a good system
yeah but like i feel like especially
when i get out of bed
i'm just like way more awake probably
the problem isn't like
when i'm out of my bed i'm awake yeah
yeah the problem the problem is the
problem isn't that problem is
getting out of the bed in the first
place yeah
like having having my legs hang off
whatever that's not going to help me
yeah sometimes the the foot out of the
bed free hanging is
pretty pretty good feeling though i
still haven't figured out i still
haven't figured out a way to get out of
bed when it's like a cold winter's day
or cold winter yeah yeah that's why i
like i'm kind of glad
now that i moved like because you know
it's starting to get warm
right yeah so it's like thank god a lot
it's a lot easier now to just
immediately get out of bed because the
inside of your mattress and
the outside of your mattress is pretty
much the same temperature yeah so it's
like it's not a [ __ ] struggle like it
is in the winter
but yeah i know i to this day i've been
trying to figure out
how the [ __ ] do i get out of bed in
winter how do i like remove the 10 g's
of force that is created
in the wintertime in my bed because it
yeah because every time
i i always do like the the one thing i
found out is like okay
one limit at a time yeah it's like stick
one arm out get that like
to room temperature right all right and
then get the next limb out and then it's
just like a slow
like processor it's like slow loading
it's it's like you know when you're like
going into the swimming pool for the
first time and it's like a really cold
pool
is it like do you jump in straight away
would you go one limb at a time i jump
in straight
away because that's that's how i feel
whenever i need to get out of bed on a
cold winter's night
you just gotta like chug a [ __ ] ton of
water when you wake up that [ __ ] wakes
you up